for months now Republicans have been
saying the Inspector General is
investigating the Russia probe when that
report comes out you will see how the
entire Russia probe was a completely
inappropriate witch-hunt inappropriately
run and also based on political bias and
the trumpian right has had a lot riding
on this for a while they've put a lot of
eggs in this office of the inspector
general report and yesterday the office
of the inspector general published the
report and it says that the Russia probe
was done in total correctly with proper
limits carried out in the right way
without political bias now they did find
some specific procedural pieces that
were problematic which I will tell you
about I have no interest in hiding that
from you but certainly not the bombshell
that Republicans and trumpets were
promising so let's go through it the
report is more than 400 pages the
highlights include that the FBI had a
quote authorized purpose when it started
its investigation the investigation was
not opened because of political animus
from the FBI against Donald Trump
informants were not used in violation of
the FBI's rules so it's a clean bill of
health for the investigation with a few
elements of wrongdoing
what were those elements well the report
says that once the investigation got
going that they believed the FBI would
sometimes emphasize information that
made Trump look bad and downplay
information that made Trump look good
now remember this is still an office
that is not without political bias but
let's grant it to them because the
entire structure and framework of the
investigation has been vindicated
I'm fine granting that maybe that is
something that took place here's an
excerpt from the report regarding
another area of controversy which is
that the surveillance of Carter Paige
specifically was heavily based on the
steel dossier the FBI request form drew
almost entirely from Steele's reporting
in describing the factual basis to a
Stabbin established probable cause to
believe that Carter Paige was an agent
of a foreign power now again I say let
just accept the criticism and move on
let them have it let them have the
critique that specifically the
surveillance of Carter page was too
heavily based on the steel dossier
it's a sliver of this entire thing let
them have it bearing in mind of course
that lots of that steel dossier it was
later corroborated now Donald Trump's
attorney general henchman William Barr
disagrees with the report that probably
doesn't surprise you he believes that
the report is just flat-out wrong of
course that it should have been much
more critical of the way the
investigation was carried out so big
picture I don't know how much time we
need to spend on this both sides are
claiming victory Democrats claim the
report completely exonerates the way the
investigation was carried out
Republicans claim that it's devastating
the reality is the report is mostly
exculpatory of the FBI's investigation
into Donald Trump and Russia in any huge
long investigation like this it's not
shocking that there were a few
procedural issues that the report was
able to find my guess is if you do this
deep of an investigation into any major
government investigation you would find
some items that at this level of
granularity could have been better
handled that is not hugely surprising to
me doesn't excuse anything but it's not
hugely surprising what you have to
remember is Republicans hyped this
report to hell and back and other than
being able to say well the Carter page
surveillance was based too heavily on
the steel dossier FBI officials played
up certain things unfairly to trump once
it got going that's all they have they
are almost better off ignoring the
report all together rather than pretend
that it's devastating to the Russia
probit because it's not and what we have
to do is ensure that we don't allow the
report to be misrepresented this is a
totally unsurprising conclusion to the
report it's good that it's done we can
now try to start moving on from this
talking point from Republicans who have
been saying just you wait until that oh
I G report destroys this an entire
investigation
that's over let's just make sure we
don't let
continue the false talking points
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom / pakman blink Asst is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
jobs by David Graeber which I listen to
on bling cos they're constantly adding
new books to the platform you will never
run out of fascinating and critically
acclaimed books to enjoy and our
audience can get a seven day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /pa k mas